a pour le groupe UMP merci monsieur le
Président euh madame la ministre la
politique familiale est au cœur de
l'actualité euh vous avez annoncé certes
la création de nouvelles places de
crèche mais aussi la réduction de moitié
de la page pour 280000 ménages une
modification euh des pensions
alimentaires non recouvrées la création
d'une allocation de 450 € pour les 18-25
ans qui ne sont ni à l'école ni en
formation ni au travail sans oublier la
baisse du plafond du C familiale et la
déductibilité pour les emplois à
domicile je ne partage pas la plupart de
ces choix mais le but de ma question est
de mesurer leur incidence sur les CAF
qui pour l'instant comme vous l'ont dit
mes collègues n'ont aucune visibilité
quant à leur futur convention
d'objectifs et de moyens comment
peuvent-elles avancer alors qu'elles ne
connaissent pas les règles du jeu le
gouvernement ile les missions
supplémentaires mais vous avez répondu à
mes collègues qui me précédaient qu'il y
aurait des moyens humains supplémentaire
mais sachez que la charge
s'accroit automatiquement avec la
précarisation croissante du public comme
dans le valde mararne ù pour désengorger
les accueils on ne passera bientôt plus
que par internet mais j'attire votre
attention et celle de de mes collègues
que cette tendance va permettre
d'accroître les risques de pishing sur
justement une population d'allocataire
de plus en plus fragilisé et qui risque
de répondre n'importe quoi j'aimerais
madame la ministre savoir si en matière
d'allocation de soutien familial les CAF
auront bien la possibilité de procéder
par prélèvement direct auprès des
employeurs comme cela se fait pour les
impôts et pourquoi faudra-t-il attendre
2016 pour que toutes les mairres
puissent bénéficier de ce système
s'agissant de la future allocation pour
les jeunes de 18 à 25 ans en rupture
avec leur famille bizarrement appelé
garantie jeune quels moyen les CAF
font-ells pour identifier les
bénéficiaires et vérifier ce critère de
rupture combien de jeunes sont ciblés
cette allocation va forcément engendrer
une surcharge de travail les CAF que
j'ai contacté en région parisienne n'ont
aucune information comment
travaillez-vous en amont avec elle pour
ne pas monter une usine à gaz merci
Madame
bertiloti c'est
toujours difficile dans une réponse en 2
minutes quand vous ciblez l'ensemble de
la politique familiale et que rien ne
recueille votre assentiment et que
jusqu'à présent l'ensemble des questions
quel que
soit la couleur politique de d'où qu'ell
viennent était quand même sur le fait
comment faire en sorte que les caisses
d'allocation familial fonctionnent
fonctionnent mieux donc moi je vais vous
répondre sur deux points un premier
point qui concerne l'accueil et au fond
c'est une façon de répondre sur la
matérialisation c'est vrai vous avez
raison de dire un certain nombre
d'allocataires ne bénéficient pas
d'internet mais par exemple vous avez
une caisse je reviens sur la caisse de
mon bellliard qui a au niveau de
l'accueil a installé tout un service
internet où il y a justement
l'apprentissage pour les allocataires
qui viennent de de l'outil Internet ils
peuvent venir tout seul une fois qu'ils
maîtrisent cet outil venir tout seul
régler tous leurs problèmes de dossier
ça pas aussi par ce type de service qui
est à rendre et qui est effectivement un
gain de temps pour tout le monde pour
les employés et pour les allocataires je
répondrai juste sur le le RSA jeune qui
est une réforme qui venait de de V rang
la la complexité du dispositif qui est
qui a
été peut-être mal mesuré empêche de
nombreux jeunes d'en profiter
aujourd'hui il y a moins de 10000
bénéficiaires de ce RSA jeune et il n'y
a pas d'aménagement prévu des conditions
d'entrée dans le RSA jeune le
gouvernement réfléchit donc à une
réforme
structurel pour satisfaire les besoins
financiers des 18 25 ans je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure Christophe cyug est
chargé d'élaborer des propositions de
réforme du RSA activité et de la prime
pour l'emploi qui ont vocation à inclure
les jeunes actifs c'est dans quelques
jours que ce rapport doit émettre ses
conclusions don il sera tenu le plus
grand compte pour être plus efficace à
l'égard de cette population merci Madame
prcia madame la ministre je vous parlez
pas du RSA jeune je vous vous parle de
la décision du gouvernement annoncé par
matigon de mettre en place à partir du
1er septembre une allocation de 450 €
pour tous les jeunes